hallo zusammen wie wird man eigentlich
auf Youtube erfolgreich apple war
pictures haben eine ganz einfache
Antwort die Konkurrenz ausschalten mehr
kreative Einfälle auf eure Fragen in den
Kommentaren und Videos jetzt im
Community Video mit tens und Schan viel
Spaß Koala 598 fragt wie lange seid ihr
beiden schon vergeben seit Februar 2010
seit dem 19 ja 19 offizielles Datum ist
der 19 1 Februar ne Schatz ja ich habe
es mir gemerkt ich bin gut top Singstar
möchte wissen wer von euch ist der
süßeste Tommy ach der süßeste ja
eigentlich schon Tommy ne
BAM der most awesome ist natürlich
wieder Stev
jaali 1994 hat eine Frage an ch wie bist
du eigentlich an deine sprechenden
Meerschweinchen gekommen und wie wann
haben sie sprechen
gelernt ich habe ich habe eigentlich
damit angefangen mit den sprechenden
Meerschweinchen wo ich Banana Split
gesehen habe das Meerschweinchen was so
aussieht wie ich halt mit dem Streifen
das habe ich damals das Meerschweinchen
das so aussieht wie ich muss man
sichzung und und da habe ich dann
irgendwann mal habe ich mir habe ich mir
gekauft das war absoluter Zufall habe
ich im Tierladen gesehen und dann habe
ich das einfach mal im Film eingebaut
dass das mal sprechen konnte ich habe
einfach meine Stimme schneller
abgelaufen bisschen hab das ein bisschen
anders betont hab das dann schneller
abgespr ablaufen lassen und das war dann
lustig D habe ich mir gedacht so dieses
Meerschweinchen ist jetzt sarkastisch
böse dreckig und gemein und dann kam das
gut an und dann habe ich gedacht machst
du noch eins dann kam das auch noch gut
an und hab GT dann ist im Team Ende und
dann haben wir noch ein paar andere
gesprochen meine erste Frage wäre an
Chan gerichtet wie schaffst du es mit 3
noch so ausesehen wie 19 benutztte head
in schers was benutzt du hast du bei her
Tutorial dir Tipps geholt ich bin
übrigens 30 nicht 33 danke finde ich
voll
nett ja weiß nicht W bei her Tutorial in
die Lehre geht nein Quatsch also einfach
purer Zufall ich würde sagen viel Sex
und nein ich R mich gerade in die
Scheiße nein einfach purer Zufall ohne
Scherz
stammzellenk geistig noch kindlich der
Körper zieht nach ja genau ge noch Kind
der Körper zieht nach glaubt ihr
zusammen bleiben könnt glaubt ihr dass
irgendwann nicht der Druck nach mehr
Privatsphäre gesichert wäre hab dass ihr
irgendwann auseinanderbrecht und dass es
nicht mal so laufen kann wie gerade habt
ihr irgendwie Angst davor ich habe keine
Angst davor ne auch keine Gefahr
irgendwie also keine Gefahr bis jetzt
sehe ich dass wir 16 unglaublich gute
Freunde sind Eck zwar hier und da ganz
selten mal an aber das gehört dazu das
Leben ist halt so man kann nicht immer
nur friedefu Eierkuchen haben aber g ist
gutes Potenzial für unsere Videos ja
weil wenn wir alle nur so hahaha
freundich drauf weren dann W auch auch
langweilig wir hoffen einfach mal dass
es immer so weiter geheht und wenn nicht
dann kann man das durch das Leben leider
auch nicht ändern aber Angst n aber du
bist als erstes Weg ja ja die super
Twins Brothers Fragen seid ihr gut in
Mario Smash Bros BR nein ne ich sacke
ich sacke auch derbe aber ich habe
eventuell Glückstreffer wenn ich Snake
nehme Snake ist sowieso der coolste vbx
ja klickum braucht mehr Waffen nicht von
uns das sind unsere kauf dir deine
eigenen ja eben findet man übrigens im
Internet bevor ihr jetzt fragt ne findet
man im Internet mega snu snu hey Chan
wenn du Noah von der Arche wärst und du
nur zwei Meerschweine mitnehmen dürftest
welche beiden wären es oh das ist schwer
aber da muss ich Männchen und Weibchen
nehmen ne ja dann muss ich ihr wird euch
überraschen aber ich würde Cookie und
cotton mitnehmen nurus RA ich will ein
Kind von dir ja kannst du da vorne eins
wegnehmen okay der G der G ist alt nein
ich ich mag keine Kinder tut mir leid
Sex muss reichen aber ich glaub da ist
auch meine Freundin nicht so
einverstanden mit die guckt mich jetzt
schon gerade böse an hallo Schatz keine
Kinder keine Kinder wie wird man auf
Youtube als Comedian denn beliebt
bekannt also ich kenne ja eine Menge
Youtuber und viele Comedians und viele
sind echte Flops und sind trotzdem
bekannt und viele sind richtig gut aber
sind nicht bekannt und wieso ist i blali
überhaupt bekannt der ist auch so ein
Flop habe ich da gerade hacast Germany
gehört nein also was hast du gegen ein
blali sorry aber hallo das ist mein
deutscher Gott ja ohne Scherz das ist
für mich der non plus ultra ja du darfst
das Hören hat drauf weiß nicht ist eine
gute Frage aberme hat eigentlich auch
momentan haben es viele drauf ja fast
schon zu viele wir müssen die Konkurrenz
Ausschalen ja warte wie wird man wie
wird beliebt auf Youtube indem man
einfach seine Konkurrenz ausschaltet
deshal haben wir so viele Waffen und
nennen uns Apple genau das ist der große
Grund nein also wir haben keine Ahnung
ich denke mal wir ziehen einfach unser
Ding durch Beobachten versuchen witzig
zu sein Anschein anscheinend findet ja
Anklang genau Community hören immer auf
die Fans hören ist ganz wichtig weil was
wär es ohne die wenn die ein sagen du
bist scheiße das war nicht das war Kacke
gemacht anderes machen neu probieren
lernen draus anders geht's nicht wenn du
l und keine Kritik vertragen kannst hast
auf Youtube nichts zu suchen Hansen
fragt wie habt ihr euch alle
kennengelernt oh das dauert jetzt eine
halbe Stunde wenn wir da rein wenn die
jetzt alle aufzählen das wirklich eine
halbe Stunde also also los emper masterj
und Shorty waren Fans genau hat im
GameStop gesagt er findet Final Fantasy
10 Scheiße erstm büßen jetzt ist es
scheiße wissen
wir jenny war eine Freundin l war
Freundin Tom die im Internet
kennengelernt waren andere Youtuber halt
hat man sich mal
getroffen und die ganzen anderen haben
sich einfach so angefunden irgendwie kam
auch kann ich noch von der
Schule Bo sind wir viele ja sind
wirklich viele W haben jetzt krimy die
Stimme hatten wir auch Netz gebucht
genau genau krimy die Stimme hab Netz
gebucht das
war's gigaplex war von Anfang an
dabeiang gaplex ist der dritte der
mitgemacht
hat den haben wir im Highlander Games
getroffen wo wir damals Magic Karten
gespielt haben wir einfach mal
reingegangen so und wir drehen jetzt ein
Film wer macht mit er K mit themach seid
dem ist er dabei ja so schnell kann es
gehen ja wir haben jetzt vergessen wir
haben bestimmt wieder ja unsere
Zeichnerin die haben wir durchs Internet
getroffen TJ möchte wissen magst du
Gronk ja ja aber warum fragt er magst du
wen von uns beiden meint er denn jetzt
ja mag meint uns also ja wir mögen Gronk
ja genau wir mögen unheimlich
sympathischer Typ ja Kohle Kohle Kohle
Kohle Kohle Kohle Kohle Kohle Kohle
Kohle Kohle Baron von westholm was
haltet ihr
voneinander halt Schan ne ja Hal t ich
meine wir würden ja nicht beste Freunde
sein wenn wir uns nicht abkönnen ich
meine wir beefen uns zwar einmmer vor
der Kamera ja ist klar aber das gehört
halt dazu du musst auch mal akzeptieren
dass du scheißäig bist ja ja und du bist
auch scheißen dumm aber trotzdem kommen
wir miteinander aus vielleicht gerade
deswegen ich wollte euch heute mal
fragen ob ihr in Zukunft noch Filme wie
Nerds V ners oder ners vs Kuchen od
geplant hab also irgendwas mit Nerds es
kommen auf jeden Fall noch ganz viele
Nerds Verss Teile ja es ist entsteht
meistens Nerds ver entsteht meistens
spontan aus dem nichtsist spontan wenn
viele Leute da sind ja bis auf ners VSS
Stromausfall der war geplant weil das
war ja ein Fanwunsch von mehreren
ansonsten ist das immer Nerds Verss wird
gedreht wenn wir jetzt nicht draußen
drehen können oder meistens nicht
draußen und es sind trotzdem ganz viele
Leute da dann sitz uns mal dahin jetzt
müssen wir die die alle mit ein binn
jetzt drehen wir ners vs irgendwas also
geht's auf jeden Fall weiter ja das ist
eine Serie die werden wir niemals
absetzen ne noch haben wir zu gute Idee
dafür und zweitens nur ob krimminer
einen eigenen Kanal hat weil ich den
Typen voll cool finde haben wir da ein
krimy Fan haben wir ein kmy Fan also Ky
hat einen eigenen Kanal the amazing
cririmy Spinner aber er LDT eigentlich
fast nichts hoch mach nur ab und zu mal
ein paar paar wei nicht wir müssen
ja die Stimme normalerweise verkörpert
er ja alles mit seiner Stimme genau
fkrone stört es eigentlich eure Nachbarn
wenn so viele bei euch in der Wohnung
sind oh ja ja ich habe jetzt schon eine
Mahnung kein Joke also wenn es mal
wieder zu viele werden und abends ab 10
Uhr wir sind zu laut ja ich habe schon
eine Mahnung aber das juckt mich nicht
weil wir eald ausziehen Danz movies 110
habt ihr vor irgendwann getrennte Wege
zu gehen nö morgen morgen ja ich kann
dich eh nicht leiden ach so ja gut ja
morgen auf dokumi gehen wir aus nicht
genau aber wir sehen uns dann ja auch
wieder also ich glaub nicht dass uns
irgendwann mal los werden hoffentlich
und ich habe noch ein Community Video
für euch mit relativ bekannten Youtubern
ihr habt vielleicht schon mal von ihnen
gehört die Außenseiter sie erzählen
unter anderem über ihre großen Pläne
oder werden danach gefragt und auch
interessant ist das mit bülenan der
nämlich nach seinem peinlichsten
Erlebnis gefragt wird und ich glaube
einen Weltrekord aufstellt im Haare um
die Nase wickeln also viel Spaß dabei
entscheidet euch links oder rechts 1 Z
oder D ach ne drei gibt's ja gar nicht
ansonsten bis dann bleib
dran